COIN IS SWEEPING THE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF THE GREATEST
THREAT TO OUR SERVICE MEN AND
WOMEN.
IT'S NOT ISLAMIC TERRORISTS OR
NUCLEAR WAR.
ACCORDING TO PRESIDENT SIPPY CUP
JOE, THE GREATEST THREAT TO OUR
MILITARY IS GLOBAL WARMING AND
HE WAS NOT JOKING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE MUST ALL COMMIT TO
AMBITTIOUS CLIMATE ACTION TO
LIMIT GLOBAL WARMING TO NO MORE
THAN 1.5 DEGREES.
I WENT IN THE TANK IN THE
PENTAGON WHEN I WAS FIRST
ELECTED VICE-PRESIDENT WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THE MILITARY STATUS DOWN TO LET
US KNOW THE GREATEST PHYSICAL
THREATS IN AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
THE JOINT CHIEF TOLD US THE
GREATEST THREAT FACING AMERICA
WAS GLOBAL WARMING.
>> Sean: OKAY, THAT GUY WILL BE
SIT DOWN WITH THE HOSTILE ACTOR
FROM RUSSIA VLADIMIR PUTIN WHO
JUST HACKED OUR ENERGY AND BEEF
INDUSTRIES.
I FEEL THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL
EAT SHO
JOE'S LUNCH AS
ALL.
VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL SEE THAT JOE
BIDEN IS FRAIL, WEAK AND
A COGNITIVE MESS THAT CAN DO
LITTLE MORE THAN READ TALKING
POINTS OFF A TELEPROMPTER AND
STRUGGLES TO DO THAT.
VICE-PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
MIGHT BE MORE INCOMPETENT.
HER TRIP TO LATIN AMERICAN WAS
A DISASTER.
SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON AT THE BORDER.
REFUSED TO COMMIT TO VISITING
THE BORDER.
I HAVE NOT BEEN TO EUROPE OR THE
MOON EITHER.
LECTURED BY LATIN AMERICAN
LEADERS BEFORE, DURING AND AFTER
HER TRIP.
EVEN CNN WAS COMPLAINING.
ONE HEADLINE READING KAMALA
HARRIS IS HAVING A BAD WEEK AND
IT'S ONLY WEDNESDAY EVEN WHITE
HOUSE STAFFERS WERE PERPLEXED BY
KAMALA HARRIS'S TERRIBLE
PERFORMANCE.
ONE DEMOCRAT TOLD THE HILL SHE
WILL BE HAUNTED BY THIS TRIP AND
THIS ISSUE FOR AS LONG AS SHE IS
IN POLITICS.
NEEDLESS TO SAY KAMALA HARRIS'S
TRIP TO GUATEMALA AND MEXICO
DIDN'T DO A SINGLE THING TO
SOLVE THE CRISIS.
IF SHE VISITED THE BORDER WE
COULD SEE THE SITUATION.
I HAVE BEEN THERE 14 TIMES.
HELICOPTERS, HORSE BACK, OUT ON
FOOT.
WATCHING PEOPLE ARRESTED.
DRUG WAREHOUSES AND TUNNELS.
I LEARN MORE EVERY TIME I GOO.
IF ANYONE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
IS WATCHING THIS.
SHOW TO, TO KAMALA HARRIS TO
LEARN SOMETHING.
MIGRANTS WERE WADING ACROSS THE
RIVER, JUST WALKING RIGHT INTO
THE COUNTRY.
THEY GET THE HELP OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS OPERATING IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT AND BREAKING OUR LAWS
AND NOT REPORTING OUR BORDERS OR
SOVEREIGNTY AND NOT BEING TURNED
AWAY.
INSTEAD THE MIGRANTS WITH
ELDERLY AND YOUNG CHILDREN ARE
HOUSED AND FED AND GET THEIR
HEALTHCARE AND EDUCATION WITH
YOUR HARD EARNED TAX DOLLARS
BECAUSE JOE AND KAMALA HARRIS
TOLD THEM TO COME.
WE WILL HAVE A 20 TO 30 YEAR
RECORD.
THEY ARE DISRESPECTING OUR LAWS
AND CONSTITUTION.
THEY ARE ENRICHING THE CART
TELES AND COSTING ALL OF US A
FORTUNE AND CUTTING IN LINE IN
FRONT OF LEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS THEY
ARE UNABLE TO SOLVE THE CRISIS.
THEY ARE AIDING AND ABETTIN